yo it's crazy so obviously we just saw
everybody get let go at ESPN it was I
mean and they've had a lot of cuts
before yeah Stephen A did a good job of
putting that out on his show like where
were you in this year and all these
people got fired and then this year all
these people got fired yeah but again
your boy Max got let go yeah who is one
of my favorites especially when it comes
to boxing I love when he is is working
the fights
um you know for people who don't know
Max Kellerman used to be a rapper
seriously oh don't even get him started
uh clip out there yeah
[Music]
got him
from Panama
um but have you spoken with Max how's he
doing and like for you just you know I
mean obviously as somebody who's kind of
doing your own thing now to witness a
line of cuts like that happening I mean
we're talking about Jeff Van Gundy I
know Jalen Rose yeah those two those are
the first two that caught me off guard
no no I think the max thing we kind of
saw coming yeah exactly Jeff Van Gundy I
was like damn but damn one all right so
Jeff Van Gundy that one caught me the
most off guard but then my second mind
kicked in like hey bro he'd be going in
on on the NBA for sure partner of ESPN I
can understand that then you dive a
little deeper you realize maybe there
was a little uh maybe yeah coffee and
tea and yeah can you let him go or else
it's gonna be tougher in our next
negotiation maybe that
um Jalen Rose caught me off guard but
then I was like yeah him and Max kind of
in the same boat they start chipping
away at what your what your products are
you entities so no more him Jalen and
Jacoby then this happens right because
the Jacoby Jalen show got cut first he
got cut first max no first take for a
while this just in which felt like a
filler show like all right you're not
here here you go yeah but how I don't
think Max leaves our show leaves LA to
do this just in and people don't think
like this but you get that in
consolation but this is why I left ESPN
in a less forced Nation it's one thing
to be getting paid and Max was getting
paid but he got paid to do first take
and now here they go with a plan B like
okay you don't Steve Steven they don't
want you on first take anymore we got
this for you right yeah but that ain't
for you that's just something to kind of
fill the time it's something for us to
to justify us paying you still exactly
yeah and so there's a huge difference
between them paying you and them
supporting you right now I feel that
SportsNation with all the rotating hosts
and co-hosts and I was like they paying
me but they don't I don't see foresight
I don't see Runway I don't see where
they're all invested in the next five
years of the show and it was tough to
call their Bluff because every time you
say that they're like oh of course we
are of course you are right and then I
said all right I'ma leave and as soon as
I left they canceled that show proven my
point I was on thin ice the show was on
thin ice one day they'll just wake up
and be like ah Sports Nation it was
novel back then 10 years ago now
everyone has a touch screen yeah
everyone interacts with the fans and
social media so I I was like uh I got
ahead of that one I felt the same for
Max I was thinking like damn this ain't
gonna last this just end even though it
wasn't a bad show it just wasn't a show
he would have left LA and he's going to
do that right so so that coming man and
you know he has a little time on he has
time to work with in terms of still
getting paid by ESPN develop what's next
he's certainly in the running for
Undisputed depending on how they really
do that but they're talking about their
rotating partnership ship what they're
doing at ESPN they might do it FS1 yeah
which makes sense which they actually
got from skip so I want to clarify
everybody thinks Steven A started this
back in the day that's what skip used to
do that's what skip used to do people
don't remember that cold pizza was
always like Woody page or Stephen A or
the twin the stoop stoop twins I
remember them I I know you're talking
about uh God I forget they're gonna kill
Armani Jones was on a lot of people
come on there yeah so it was a thing
before Stephen A revamped it and now
skip may go back to it
um let me ask you this do you feel like
the way because I I feel like the Pat
McAfee thing happening and then all of
this these Cuts happening and Stephen A
starting his own show I feel like none
of these are coincidental oh no it's not
right I'm like okay well they had to pay
this guy however much they had to pay
him for him to walk away from that
FanDuel deal shout out to him for yeah
being comfortable enough to do that but
at the same time you got oh look Steven
A launches his own thing on YouTube like
do you feel like Pat McAfee
in the same way that Skip and Stephen a
kind of changed what moves the needle in
traditional TV ratings on Sports
networks with debate by the way PTI was
the first to kind of do that but
um Do You Feel Like Pat McAfee's
changing the sports broadcasting
industry yeah he's he's the one that
shows the proof of concept the best in
sports
um you know you combine that with the
Paul Brothers you combine that with Joe
Rogan yeah yeah everything starts
getting crazy right but in sports like
it's McAfee
um and the beautiful thing is I I keep
going back to it he ain't even raised
his hand to do it but you know what he
was doing he didn't know it
um he was falling in an alignment where
the industry had to go so let's go way
back to like 98.99 when Bill Gates first
said content is King and everyone's
heard that right but we didn't really
understand it because we didn't have the
proper mediums and the proper conduits
to do that so content is King before
social media is really big meant what I
stay in the studio longer my show is
longer what's content is Keen but what
he really meant then and I was just at a
summit speaking in Silicon Valley about
this where all the tech Guru CEOs are
talking VCS now that this world
especially Sports media is going to
change and morph into everyone is a
Creator and everyone is a channel now
some people are already pushing back
probably thinking I ain't a channel I'm
not a Creator everybody is if you got an
Instagram well no let's go oh
content creator technically yes if
someone is following you that's giving
you attention if you post something
someone's given that some sort of
attention you might get two likes there
you go that is content you may get two
likes but if you talk about interaction
engagement did someone slow down on it
right there yeah because that's what
they look on the back here they're
trying to measure those metrics and
they're like oh that was interesting
okay now we're going to change your feed
algorithm for that point being you are a
creator
on a grander scale that is Pat McAfee he
just started to plug away during a
three-hour show every single day and
falling into alignment where everything
had to go so now everything is going out
and very unedited very unhinged when it
came to the language he's using it it
was like oh this guy doesn't work for
nobody so he could say whatever the [__]
he was he wants and it was sick and I I
mean and he played you know I'm watching
one of my contemporaries doing the same
thing broadcasting play ball like I did
and then I'm watching him in a tank top
curse about the same topic that I'm over
here hello in a suit you look at all
Prima price it's like who do who who's
the fans gonna want to see they want to
see the uncut version of that or right I
wanted to see yeah so I'm like you know
getting off the studio desk everyone is
bowing down to me oh look Marcel's on TV
TV linear cable respect which it is of
course of course it's a different animal
if it wasn't Pat McAfee wouldn't be on
ESPN if it didn't matter because it does
still matter because he he took he's
he a lot of people think he walked away
from you know maybe a little bit more
money no they got that wrong too oh did
they oh let me tell you all right so
let's just say the FanDuel deal is 120.
if it's 120 that's what they reported
and then it gets 85 from ESPN everybody
already initially kind of ran with it
the wrong way
120 from FanDuel is here Pat do
everything else with it pay every pay
yourself
yeah pay the whole crew whoever Roxanne
Jones everybody all of them yeah and run
that operation and you deal with all
that tax attorneys yeah or I give you 85
and then we pay your crew and then I go
AJ come here you come in here next
nobody talking about his deal Asia
here's your five year 25 whatever it may
be so everybody starts getting that it
grows greater than the 120 he got from
FanDuel and everybody's secure everyone
gets their health insurance through
somebody it ain't on Pat McAfee's
diamonds Etc all these things the
benefits like it's insane so he took a
better deal on top of a grander platform
and he's gonna be able to do so much
like if he just hosted the ass piece you
know like they threw them in last minute
last minute and he killed it he killed
it that's that's the thing like he still
gets to do what he's doing but he also
gets that turbo boost that nitrous from
ESP by the way shout out to AJ Hawk for
never having to leave his house and and
and just they somehow did such a good
job because you know I'm so against Zoom
content like when we do interviews and
stuff for the most part yeah I noticed
that when we were setting it up you're
like bruh
look like if if Drake was like we have
to do it all right Drake's that's what
you're saying I'm just I mean like
you're what you're but you're in town
you know like I think we've maybe done
two or three Zoom interviews in the last
three years I think one of them was uh
Tyrese you let Tyrese off the hook he
from L.A no man we did that for that we
did that more for the radio Drake got a
spot in in La too so who you letting off
the hook these people these cats live in
L.A dog TLC
all right
uh but yeah it wasn't what was the other
one oh yeah and then like uh but for my
[__] I think that's the only two like oh
and then goodie mop they were in Atlanta
and it was middle of the pandemic oh
okay so this was like early pandemic
they don't dance no more okay I'll give
you some of that but but but they've
done a good job of figuring out a way to
make the remote thing work oh yeah ESPN
does that everybody they do nobody even
notices anymore yes because I think in
the hip-hop space people notice really
yeah like when you're not doing like an
in-person interview in the music space
people notice that's a great Point
Sports we're so used to seeing everybody
Mike wilbon's in Arizona or yes
cornhusers in DC and nobody yeah and so
like you know just kind of finish your
point and finish what we were talking
about
everyone's gonna become a Creator you
already are but you're gonna become like
you're gonna lean into it and really
realize that's who you are even if
you're an old lady just sitting there
showing pictures of your grandkids
you're a Creator what comes from that
is now you're going to all understand
you have to license that out
um and what ESPN just bought into was
the first licensing of a Creator yeah so
they now it's a proof of concept on
YouTube second most Googled which Google
owns YouTube but second most used search
engine is YouTube right behind Google
which owns YouTube yeah so what they are
doing is they're like ah we're creating
what has to be created with your
creators right now traditional media
whether that's linear cable or
traditional media has to now buy into
all of us because we are where the
people are so reason I took off my suit
ultimately is I was making 1.9 million
dollars I hate this world we can't tell
kids and people how much you're making
like in football everybody know how much
you make right everybody everybody
they know every little detail every
little Clause yeah point zero well you
know if it makes it Pro Bowl this year
that's an extra 500k or Kyler Murray has
to study right and then I get it that
was funny
um these thin like these these like
fragile egos or fragile industry well we
saw a lot of these salaries the guys who
just got fired and even like God yeah
I'm like why are we High guys like
Keyshawn Johnson was eating not not was
he signed a five-year deal and only did
one year of it he's getting paid for the
next four years when I saw the Keyshawn
Johnson number and listen the morning
show was decent it wasn't great Keyshawn
is a decent on like like obviously a
legendary player he's done a great job
dog that's not a dog yeah listen L.A
Legend SC Legend oh here come my butt
when I saw that number I was like oh you
forgot Keyshawn always hit him over the
head football contract Tampa Bay his
agent
I think he's his own agent whoever
agency is negotiating his [__] I said oh
man good for him but you know the real
of that is he got that deal
God let me let me untangle this for
y'all so max is making that big first
take money right then they're like all
right Stephen A him ain't going right
mix water and oil because they ended up
putting Max on with Keyshawn right yeah
that's what that morning show yeah so
this is how it is Keyshawn was already
there they got rid of the Zubin guy
right he got sick and then it just left
something like that so then Max comes in
but Max making first take money that's
the most expensive morning show ever
right for a radio show right at all time
so did Keyshawn sitting there like um he
came to my hood this my show whose name
is first Keyshawn yeah so he used that
as leverage that's how he got that
though oh yeah it's games so you were
making you were making 1.9 I was making
1.9 which is you know I mean like I'm in
a minus territory mostly that's great
though most people you see don't make
that and you were were you being were
you in LA or you were going to uh
Connecticut L.A okay all L.A which was
great it was a great fit for my life
it's just it I plateaued first of all
I'm the realest it's just like being an
athlete I knew when I was sorry now
everyone else will say it before me but
I acknowledge it when y'all saying it
too when an athlete's coming down the
hill he knows it he just ain't gonna
admit it he won't admit it everyone else
is gonna say it so I knew I would
Plateau because the three big dogs in my
industry I never could be like them and
that's a positive for them and just a
difference for me
Stephen A Skip and Colin so this is how
I look at life man it's the science of
life I'm like all right all three of
them didn't play at the highest level
so there's a different level of
communication and investment right then
I'm like all right they all go places I
wouldn't go because I'm not trying to be
condensed into that great headline
that's spicy I don't go in on the camera
you'll notice a lot less of the crueler
takes coming from actual people who
played right exactly so I was like damn
I'm not a hot take artist
um and people think that's with a
negative connotation I'm like no that's
just a brand we're all in the circus
just different tents my tent is not that
so I was like so how much can I make in
my tent now start looking around I was
like think you making the most in this
tent bro so I was like do you bet again
my next negotiation was going to be a
haircut using the pandemic and of course
all this stuff so I was like then I'm
looking at my neighbors I'm like these
suckers are going downstairs in these
content houses destroying life and
moving in next to me so I was like all
right we talked through the negotiation
basically
I started my own show downstairs in my
house I'm just going downstairs so it
was your decision to leave FS1 so yeah
so that's on your own terms both times
Well if they would pay me 10 million but
both times leaving ESPN and FS1 you left
on your own oh yeah like there well
there are other opportunities and shows
for me to go there yeah no but you you
were like hey I'm gonna move on to FS1
because I have a a place where maybe I
can showcase who I am more yeah and then
once the FS1 thing ran its course yeah
free agency like you got other offers
are they better offers my mind at
leaving FS1 was this
there was three levels of me Landing the
plane the first one was we're not doing
speak for yourself anymore because
whitlock's not here who designed that
whole show he was there from the
beginning well you're there when it
became you weren't there when it became
speak no no that's when I was out
because they were telling me about that
right and I was like damn I'm going
backwards in life no slight to them
because I already did Sports Nation and
I was like I've already done the the
four person panel all that you've been
there done and they're done that the top
layer we're going to talk about Cowboys
we're going to talk the Lakers I've done
that and I was like damn I got so many
more muscles to flex that I won't get
the flex in that format on this show but
they paying you so much they're paying
you to be in that velvet coffin right
right like just just die slowly with us
shut up you know what I mean and so I
was like damn
level two was the fact that the offer
wasn't going to be as Grand as my
imagination of being out here being on
YouTube letting Brands plug into me
sponsors plug into me going direct to
Consumer and number three was frankly we
start talking about other shows building
the show out in my home which we started
um first things first which I love but
it's in New York it was conversations of
it coming to La it didn't happen then I
was like now I'm going I'm chasing money
because the only reason I'm gonna do
this is because they're paying me I
would never want to be in New York away
from my kids I would never want to go
over here and be away from my kids and
just travel and do the circuit I done
that right but I don't want to do that
and then you know using my network and
knowing what I know and wanted to lean
into my Foundation I said you know what
Just Do Your Own Thing regain do the
work man yeah
and then let's roll and then YouTube's
doing well it is and you you got I mean
almost six months do you have
um somebody handling your brand
Partnerships and your sponsorships or do
you do a lot of that yourself or do you
yeah someone's handling it but I I mean
I'm always cc'd I'm always chiming in uh
you know only I know my own secret sauce
did they get your Bluetooth yet the
Bluetooth are you Bluetooth up yet what
is that you got to get that Bluetooth
man what is that they sponsor our show
oh is that some food or something dipped
uh it's like a dick pill
my wife said get it everybody get that
boy the ingredient is Byron Cialis use
the promo code bootleg oh and you'll get
a month for free voice move with that
okay